real quick
he's put he put he put it in there and
got a little bit of decoration on it
yeah look at that
that's how you get the decoration marks
and then he's giving it some air from
the other side
we're at Seaton or at the casino a glass
factory
he's slowly blowing it overtime okay he
just dumped it in water and it's going
right back in so sweet
silica sand huh this is what it looks
like he's cooling down the rod now
Wow Wow
this is just a little demonstration okay
when we really produce depended by what
we have to do then depend the size
anyway here we make chandelier
chandelier is a pretty classic city
unity company anyway it's a group of 12
studio like this one all world is
together on Morana
okay twelve oh not only one this is just
now a Democrat because of August but
every the work is six people working
together and the same family lonely is
the same time it's a family business
they said is why we are investing our
time for about you because it's a family
business badasses on generation to
generation Dorothy how long back to the
1346 energy watch the wall yeah there it
is
now tell me we said like most of you at
enemy towers under the end the most of
you tell it's our trouble class as you
press it thank you for the tour this is
amazing
can I blow glass that's how we
I know the defendant what we have
what other hero
Wow
people each other the anyone directly
yeah yeah
like that I mean
I can do I can do a good job let me go
one time no definitely not a no no I
haven't I have a so many other islands
and ideas but you guys are experts I
can't compete no way give this no no
chance too many Club 5 euro per question
[Laughter]
so how many normally people work at a
time shoot six people here
oh yeah that's right don't touch the
glass how long does it have to cool down
the glass good that glass is gonna break
why interesting okay so if it cools down
without the cooling machine it will cool
down too fast and break so you need to
bring the temperature overtime yeah
three days
big stuff three days then that means you
cool it by like one degree Celsius every
every couple minute
yeah yeah
[Music]
Wow 600 meters greater 24-hour correct
you
21:30 max for me
[Music]
five bucks yeah so this corporation is
six-person Judy needs that the heck you
tag older things exponential the camera
working here
aha
because for health health because this
is also very hot they stand next to it
all day yeah
to remind that work the clock you know
away from athletes are very denying
everything yeah
one great seer in the tails
oh yeah what's wrong with the silica
sand why is that a bad why is it about
it's bad for up to inhaler
oh there's lead and arsenic not in here
both boat all from the 60s no more but
in the past there was lead and arsenic
this is recyclable so you take this and
you can melt it no yeah but then but
then what do you do with the pieces that
don't make it
yeah with recycled glass cool so silica
sand is sourced to France is that is 23%
and then what what do you have to do
with the silica sand in order for it to
mold into glass you have to do anything
add water your special elements yes
secret compositions yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah over there okay
okay no worries California yeah yeah
it's beautiful
we love your city we love Venice we love
Venice grazie Mille